Nikki great to see you're urging people
not to buy 250 brands that's half the
market incredible it's huge and it's a
big step to take but essentially we
became aware last year that products
refrigeration products made with plastic
backing could be unsafe to consumers so
since then we have been testing
rigorously appliances that are made with
plastic backing to see just how safe
they are and sadly we found that they're
not safe enough and they do risk
accelerating the speed of fire spreading
the association of manufacturers
domestic appliances who we just quoted
there they say you're you're causing
unnecessary concern and fear and alarm
among consumers how do you react react
to that so it's true that all products
that are currently on the market
do pass existing safety standards but
what we're saying is these safety
standards don't go far enough they're
inadequate they're not fit for purpose
and they certainly don't replicate what
a real fire in the home would look like
and it's also true to say that actually
the risk of a fire from a refrigeration
appliance is fairly low they're around
3,200 appliance fires every year and
about 8% can be accounted for from
refrigeration products it's low but it's
it's not low enough when it's possible
to make safe and appliances with metal
backs well clearly I'm in the grand
Fatah fire being a case in points
started with a with a fridge I'm you
were onto this before then what would
alert you that the fact that this was
such a widespread issue so we were
working closely with the London Fire
Brigade and we saw evidence from them
that suggested that products made with a
plastic backing were unsafe and we then
started looking at the safety standards
and thought that they were inadequate
and designed our own tests that would
more rigor rigorously assess the safety
of these appliances so what we did was
and we applied a naked flame to plastic
backings and metal backings to see how
quickly they went up in flames and no
metal backing with withstood a flame for
more than 30 seconds I mean the
Americans as I understand it have
insisted on metal backings for fridges
and freezers for years what why don't we
in this country absolutely and this
problem doesn't exist in the US and in
the u.s. there's also there's a single
body that has responsibility for
oversight of product safety and
enforcement when it comes to products
safe
we don't have such a body like that in
the UK it's a very fragmented regime
we're calling on government to really
start looking at that and and
essentially overhaul a system for
assessing product safety presumably this
is because it's there's an eu-wide
regulation potentially after brexit the
UK government would be free to toughen
up the rules absolutely and it but it's
really essential that there is that
there is a national body that's looking
at this to ensure that we are not left
at risk after after with X at the EU so
you're fairly optimistic that changes
are coming well we hope so we're calling
on manufacturers and retailers to stop
selling these products urgently and we
know that there is an appetite from
industry to do something about it and to
toughen up the current standards and
that will happen from next year but we
want immediate action now all right
Nikki Stoffel from which gotta leave it
there thanks for joining making